so we have an interesting problem or
exercise here find a such that the limit
as X approaches 0 of the square root of
4 plus X minus the square root of 4
minus a times X all of that over X is
equal to 3/4 and like always I encourage
you to pause the video and give a go at
it so assuming you have had your go now
let's do this together so when you just
try to superficially evaluate this limit
here if X approaches 0 so if you just
try to evaluate this one x equals 0
you're going to get so let me just try
to evaluate the limit as X approaches 0
of the square root of 4 plus X minus the
square root of 4 minus a X all of that
over X well this right over here is
going to be just the principal root of 4
because 4 plus 0 is 4 this right over
here is going to be the principal root
of 4 because well no matter what a is a
times 0 is going to be 0 so you're going
to be left with 4 minus 0 so it's just
the principal root of 4 so you're gonna
have to this whole thing is going to be
2 if you just were to substitute of X
there so this whole thing is 2 this
whole thing right over here is going to
be 2 as well you're going to have 2
minus 2 and then as exports to 0 this is
going to be 0 so this looks like we are
going we are getting an indeterminate
form and when you get to something like
this you start to say well lapa tiles
rule might apply if I get 0 for 0 or
infinity over infinity
well this limit is going to be the same
thing as the limit as X approaches 0
this is going to be the same thing as
the limit as X approaches 0 of the
derivative of the numerator over the
derivative of the denominator so what is
the derivative of the numerator so
actually let's do the derivative of the
denominator first because the derivative
of X with respect me I'm going to then a
different color the derivative of X with
respect to X is just going to be 1 but
now let me take the derivative of this
this business up here the derivative the
derivative of this with respect to X so
this is 4 plus X to the 1/2 power
so this is good the derivative of this
part it's going to be 1/2 times 4 plus X
to the negative 1/2 power and so the
derivative of this part right over here
let's see here the the chain rule
applied here but the derivative of 4
plus X is just 1 so we just multiply
this thing by 1 but here the chain rule
the derivative of 4 minus ax with
respect to X is negative a now we
multiply that I'm going to have this
negative out front so this is going to
be plus a plus a times times 1/2 times 4
minus a X to the negative 1/2 power I
just use the power rule and the chain
rule to take the derivative here and so
what is this going to be well this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to something over 1 so we have up
here as X approaches 0 this is going to
be this part 4 plus 0 is just 4 to the
negative 1/2 power well that's just
going to be one half for the 1/2 is 2 4
to the negative 1/2 is 1/2 and then as X
approaches 0 here this is going to be 4
to the negative 1/2 which is once again
1/2 so what does this simplify to
we have 1/2 times 1/2 which is 1/4
that's that there and then over here I
have a times 1/2 times 1/2 so that's
going to be plus a over 4 and so this is
the same thing as just a plus 1 over 4
and we say that this needs to be equal
to 3/4 this needs to be equal to 3/4
that was our original problem so that
needs to be equal to 3/4 and now it's
pretty straightforward to figure out
what a needs to be a plus 1 needs to be
equal to 3 or a is equal to 2 and we are
done